Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar. Four circles of equal size are inscribed in a square.
Inside of the four circles is a smaller square tangent to each of the four circles.
If the large square has a side length equal to four, what is the area of the small square?
Can you figure it out? Give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching the video for the solution.
The first thing we'll do is: we'll consider the centers of each circle.
Now, we'll solve for the radius of a single circle.
If, we extend the radius across two adjacent circles, we'll see that it spans the side of the large square
The large square side is equal to four times the length of the radius of a single circle, and this is equal to four.
So, we can solve that each circle has a radius r equals one.
Now, let's form a triangle between the centers of three circles.
This will be an isosceles right triangle, where each leg is equal to two.
The hypotenuse of this isosceles right triangle will be two times the square root of two (2*√2). You can solve for this by the Pythagorean theorem.
But, we can also solve for the length of the hypotenuse by considering the distances involved.
We have one radius length.
Then, we have the length of the small square, which we'll denote by x, and then we have another radius length.
So, we now have two different ways to measure the hypotenuse.
On the one hand, it's equal to two square root of two, and on the other hand, it's equal to two plus x, where x is the small square side length.
We can therefore solve that x is equal to 2 square root of two minus two.
This means the area of the small square is the square of x which equals
twelve minus eight square root of two and that's approximately
point six eight six.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video! Please subscribe to my channel.
I make videos on math.
You can catch me on my blog: Mind Your Decisions. Which you can follow on Facebook, google+ and patreon.
You can catch me on social media at @PreshTalwalkar. If you liked this video,
please check out my books there are links in the video description.